qué es lo que le sucede a un submarino
con la presión subacuática y por qué se
ha podido dar esta implosión
Gracias por la oportunidad
normalmente cuando un sumergible se
encuentran debajo del agua reciben una
presión que es la columna vertical de
esa columna de agua sobre el casco el
residente del submarino si hay alguna
situación anormal con el casco esta
presión puede superar la capacidad de
ruptura del casco haciendo que ese se
fracture y ocasionándole
por tanto entiendo que podríamos estar
hablando de una falla en el sumergible
que ha provocado este esta implosión y
quería preguntarle una nave como esta
entonces tiene unas horas de emisión
máximas y revisiones periódicas al
estilo de las que tienen los aviones
normalmente nuestro marido
convencionales de ataque tienen unas
horas de trabajo el casco resistente
está diseñado para trabajar a una
profundidad y en la medida que él se
vaya exigiendo hay que hacer una
revisión es periódicas al casco para
confirmar que se encuentre en perfectas
condiciones para seguir operando eso
ocurre en los submarinos convencionales
de ataque en el caso de sumergible me
imagino que las mismas condiciones deben
aplicar para poder garantizar que este
casco esté soportando las presiones a
las cuales está llegando
y una vez ha ocurrido este suceso ve
posible que se puedan llegar a encontrar
los cuerpos otras la tras la implosión
sería imposible además con las
corrientes submarinas podrían estar
quizás a kilómetros de hundimiento
Pues todos Esperamos que se puedan
encontrar los cuerpos de las personas
para dar digamos tranquilidad a sus
familiares algo de tranquilidad dentro
de esta situación pero es una operación
muy compleja porque si está a 4000
metros de profundidad la situación de
rescatar o recuperar a las los restos y
a las personas es bien compleja y un
poco probable
y la guardia costera hablaba de ruido
subacuáticos que escuchaban y que
podrían venir del sumergible parece que
ahora igual descartan esa posibilidad si
no venían de él que podría haber causado
esos ruidos a una distancia tan profunda
pues la esperanza inicialmente que todos
teníamos era que fueran mensajes
enviados desde la tripulación dentro del
submarino del sumergible perdón pero al
parecer esto pudo haber sido estos
sonidos de el momento de la inclusión
porque eso puede ser registrado por
sensores acústicos al fondo del mar